C'est une pratique très récente qui n'est pas cohérente avec les modèles bibliques d'exposition de la parole de Dieu,
qui n'est pas cohérente avec la manière de Dieu de révéler sa parole à nous,
et qui n'est pas cohérente avec l'histoire de l'Église.
Et c'est ce qu'on appelle des prédications thématiques,
des choix envers quelques portions des Écritures qui sont susceptibles tout simplement aux impressions qui sont toujours imparfaites,
aux intuitions qui ne sont pas si sécurisées des prédicateurs.
Et l'un des arguments qu'ils utilisent, c'est qu'ils parlent à,
ils se sentent plus dirigés par les Saint-Esprits,
les moments où ils vont choisir certains passages des Écritures.
Et nous ne sommes pas en train de nier le fait que les Saint-Esprits dirigent son peuple,
qu'il exerce son influence sur son peuple.
Mais c'est juste de nous rappeler de l'incohérence avec la manière des dieux de révéler l'Évangile.
En ajoutant couche sur couche,
en établissant une ligne de raisonnement très claire,
en nous permettant de construire notre compréhension
de la révélation des dieux envers Christ
de manière linéaire, progressive.
C'est tout simplement la manière dont Dieu a révélé
la vérité à propos de l'Évangile dans sa parole.
C'est aussi le même modèle qu'on trouve dans les prédications,
dans les Écritures.
Et c'est aussi la manière dont l'Église,
et surtout l'Église réformée,
a toujours cherché à exposer la parole de Dieu.
En faisant confiance,
que c'est de cette manière que les Saint-Esprits
a établi la parole,
et les Saint-Esprits a les premiers intéressés
à honorer cette manière de prêcher la parole de Dieu.
L'un des plus grands avantages,
c'est tout simplement de savoir que nous ne serons jamais
les otages
des préférences des prédicateurs.
Préférences
qui parfois
les permettent de se cacher
de certaines portions des Écritures
qui peuvent exposer
leurs faiblesses,
leurs faiblesses théologiques,
ou même leurs faiblesses éthiques.
On n'est pas voulant
s'exposer publiquement
à la confrontation
de l'Évangile
envers certaines choses
qui sont évidentes.
Mais c'est une preuve aussi
que les Saint-Esprits
sont constamment en train d'honorer
en apportant cette fraîcheur
que tous les textes bibliques apportent,
mais en démontrant aussi
la capacité des dieux
et du Saint-Esprit
de répondre
de manière
extraordinaire et surprenante
à certains événements
qui ont lieu.
Donc on n'a même pas besoin parfois,
même si c'est légitime,
de changer les thèmes
de la prédication
à cause
d'un événement
très puissant
qui a lieu entre nous.
On a tous accompagné
l'assassinat de cet homme
qui a eu le privilège,
un privilège rare
même entre les martyrs chrétiens,
d'avoir comme dernier mot
qui sort de sa bouche
une proclamation claire
de l'évangile.
Et nous étions
la semaine
même où il était mort
en train d'étudier
cette relation
entre
l'assassinat d'Étienne
et la croissance explosive
de l'Église.
et nous pouvons être sûrs
que le Saint-Esprit
était en train
de nous préparer
par l'exposition
de la parole de Dieu
à comprendre,
à digérer
et au lieu de développer
un esprit de défaite,
être rassuré
que c'est la manière
dont l'Évangile progresse.
Et donc ça,
c'était juste un exemple
de la manière
dont le Saint-Esprit
honore l'exposition
suivie des Écritures.
Et peut-être
avec une nuance
encore moins sévère
mais qui reste réelle,
c'est la Providence
qui nous donne aussi
l'opportunité
de méditer
sur l'importance
d'une notion
des membres
responsables
d'Église,
la notion
du baptême
avec ces passages
car on va commencer
aujourd'hui même
à nouveau
parcours des membres
au sein de cette Église.
Et donc Dieu
et le Saint-Esprit
continuent d'honorer
sa parole
de manière très vivante
et fraîche
et il le parle
encore aujourd'hui
et il honore
cette manière
d'exposer les Écritures.
Donc ce qu'on a médité
sur ces textes,
c'était
avec l'intention
d'expérimenter
une rentrée
qui ne soit pas
sous la pression
mondaine
d'établir
ou de rétablir
des résolutions
focalisées
sur des objectifs
pré-temporels
qui peuvent être légitimes
mais qui restent
rémondants
car c'est la pratique
qu'on a
et d'avoir
une perception
renouvelée
de notre vraie identité.
Et ce qui acte
des apôtres
vise à nous présenter
c'est la croissance
assurée
de l'Église
c'est la réalité
du Christ
ressuscité
qui a été élevé
dans son ascension
pour occuper
ses trônes
des gloires
cet empire
ces royaumes
qui est
un royaume
irrésistible
et perpétuel
et qui manifeste
son triomphe
par la croissance
de l'Église
à travers
ses ambassadeurs
c'est-à-dire
nous sommes tous
des témoins
du Christ
si nous sommes
chrétiens
et ça c'est
la principale vérité
à propos de nos vies
ça parle
de la plus grande
source des joies
que nous puissions avoir
dans cette vie
savoir que nous sommes
ambassadeurs
du royaume du Christ
et savoir
que nous pouvons
être utilisés
pour la réconciliation
entre les perdus
et les Christ
qui donne encore
une opportunité
de répentance
et réconciliation
à toute l'humanité
et qui dans sa position
des rois suprêmes
un jour
reviendra
pour juger
les vivants
et les morts
et donc ça parle
de la plus grande
pertinence
que nous puissions avoir
dans cette vie
et ça parle aussi
de l'enterprise
la plus rassurée
que nous pouvons
nous engager
dans cette vie
car pour tout autre
objectif des vies
pour tout autre
projet des vies
nous n'avons
aucune assurance
certaine
que nous allons
triompher ou prospérer
mais pour cette
entreprise
nous avons
l'assurance divine
et donc à la mesure
où Luc
est en train
d'enregistrer
et d'écrire
comment cette promesse
du Christ
en acte chapitre 1
vous serrez
mes témoins
en Jérusalem
Judée
Samarie
jusqu'à
les extrémités
de la terre
est en train
de se dérouler
dans l'histoire
de l'église
dans sa jeunesse
et c'est une histoire
qui continue
jusqu'au retour
du Christ
donc ça montre
les paramètres
de qui nous sommes
de comment nous devons
exercer
les témoignages
du Christ
l'évangélisation
comment l'église
doit s'organiser
et comment l'église
a progressé
de Jérusalem
Judée
Samarie
jusqu'aux extrémités
de la terre
déjà en acte
et la continuité
avec nous
donc dans ces passages
l'éthiopien
représente
un acte
selon l'intentionalité
de Luc
représente
Philippe
qui était responsable
pour participer
de la pénétration
de l'évangile
en Samarie
et ensuite
aux extrémités
de la terre
représentée
par le Luc
et donc
la vérité centrale
pour nous
c'est que
d'être témoigné
ou être
un témoin
c'est l'un des objectifs
suprêmes
pour chaque chrétien
et la question clé
qu'on a posée
c'est comment
les modèles
ou les paramètres
de Philippe
doit
enflammer
notre identité
en tant que témoin
du Christ
et servir
des paramètres
pour la manière
dont on témoigne
à propos de Jésus Christ
donc
comme Philippe
la première réponse
qu'on a considérée
nous devons être
des messagers
soumis
à la direction
du Seigneur
et à la conduite
de son esprit
donc je ne vais pas
revenir
car on a déjà
médité sur ça
mais
les versets 26
à 29
nous démontrent
la manière
dont un ange
va apparaître
à Philippe
un ange envoyé
par les Christs
donc l'autorité
suprême du Christ
qui a les premiers
intéressés
et les premiers
!
les premiers déterminés
dans les saluts
des perdus
qui va
cet ange
sera responsable
pour enlever
l'attention
de Philippe
d'un ministère
très prospère
en Samarie
avec des multitudes
des miracles
des signes
pour aller au désert
pour toucher
une seule âme
et donc c'est cet ange
qui apparaît
pour lui
et les textes
nous disent aussi
que l'esprit
lui-même
a dit à Philippe
de s'approcher
de cet homme
donc c'était un homme
un vrai témoin
de Christ
qui était sensible
à la direction
du Saint-Esprit
qui était soumis
à la direction
du Saint-Esprit
Philippe
qui a reconnu
en acte 6
comme un homme
rempli du Saint-Esprit
démontre
être rempli
du Saint-Esprit
par sa soumission
prompte
à la direction
du Saint-Esprit
le deuxième aspect
qu'on a considéré
c'est que Philippe
ou comme Philippe
nous devons participer
de manière ordinaire
et intentionnelle
même stratégique
de la grande mission
du Christ
et comment nous apprenons ça ?
Nous apprenons ça
car Philippe
n'était pas
à l'attente
de voir un ange
ou de recevoir
une impression
explicite
audible
du Saint-Esprit
pour s'engager
dans l'évangélisation
le chapitre 8
commence
verset 4 à 8
en nous démontrant
qu'il était
lui-même
en train
de partager
l'évangile
en Samarie
qu'il y prêcha
les Christ
et les foules
toutes entières
étaient attentives
à ce que Philippe
disait
et lorsqu'ils apprirent
et virent
les miracles
qu'ils faisaient
car des esprits
ont pu sortir
des plusieurs démoniaques
en poussant des cris
et beaucoup
des paralytiques
et boiteux
furent guéris
et il y a eu
une grande joie
dans cette vie
cette joie
qui va toujours
accompagner
les vraies conversions
et donc c'est intéressant
de remarquer
que Philippe
faisait partie
de ces chrétiens
qui après la persécution
déclenchée
par l'assassinat
les tienne
se sont éparpillés
les chrétiens laïcs
dans sa majorité
car les apôtres
sont restés
à Jérusalem
et on a vu
comment l'évangile
passe de Jérusalem
à Judée
à Samarie
et donc
Philippe
il était en train
d'obéir
de manière ordinaire
à la promesse
et au commandement
du Seigneur Jésus Christ
lorsqu'il a dit
vous serez mes témoins
en Jérusalem
à Samarie
et donc nous
devons être toujours
sensibles
à la direction
du Saint-Esprit
mais en général
nous serons plus
exposés
aux manifestations
spectaculaires
du Saint-Esprit
non si nous sommes
en train de chercher
ça comme la fin
mais comme
les moyens
pour accomplir
ce qui est
le ministère principal
du Saint-Esprit
selon la promesse
du Christ
vous recevrez
les Saint-Esprits
et vous allez
donc commencer
à parler en langue
ou manifester
des signes
des prodiges
non c'est pas ça
Jésus dit
vous recevrez
mon esprit
et vous serez
mes témoins
ces dons
peuvent venir
pour nous équiper
à accomplir
ces buts
mais l'exhortation
des pôles
envers l'église
des Corinth
qui pratiquait
les plus sécheuses
c'était de mettre
en question
s'ils étaient
véritablement remplis
du Saint-Esprit
car malgré
la manifestation
de ces dons
ils n'étaient pas
soumis
au Saint-Esprit
et quand Paul
va parler
de la soumission
au Saint-Esprit
les signes
d'être remplis
du Saint-Esprit
en Ephésiens
chapitres 4
5 et 6
ne vous iniberez
pas du vent
mais soyez
remplis
du Saint-Esprit
et tout de suite
soyez soumis
les uns aux autres
femmes aux maris
employés aux employeurs
les maris
et les employeurs
à Christ
et donc
cette facilité
à obéir
la volonté
de Dieu
c'est l'un des signes
principaux
de la présence
du Saint-Esprit
entre nous
obéissance
sanctification
Saint-Esprit
c'est pas
car l'Esprit
est plus sang
que les Pères
ou les Fils
c'est car
son ministère
particulier
envers nous
c'est de produire
cette soumission
facile
à la volonté
de Dieu
pour l'obéir
et ça peut parler
de notre pratique
de vie
notre éthique
quotidienne
notre moralité
ça parle aussi
de cette commission
à évangéliser
être rempli
de Saint-Esprit
c'est d'obéir
cette commission
et Philippe
était en train
de le faire
de manière
très ordinaire
le troisième aspect
c'est que
comme Philippe
nous devons être
capables
et toujours
prêts
à proclamer
Christ
selon
l'écriture
donc on a
médité
et deux des plus
importantes
leçons
de ces passages
c'est d'être
devant
un modèle
un paramètre
biblique
d'évangélisation
et voilà pourquoi
aujourd'hui
on a besoin
de ça
car nous devrions
confronter
toute pratique
actuelle
moderne
d'évangélisation
à ce que nous
trouvons ici
nous ne devrions pas
chercher à apprendre
à faire l'évangélisation
avec les évangélistes
d'aujourd'hui
avec les méthodes
d'évangélisation
d'aujourd'hui
on devrait
évaluer
si leur méthode
est biblique
à partir
des paramètres
des écritures
et selon
les paramètres
des écritures
nous ne sommes pas
devant
une interaction
automatique
où certains
sont en train
de vomir
certaines vérités
sans aucune
apparence
des réelles
compassions
empathie
envers les perdus
nous devons
obéir
et faire
l'évangélisation
mais nous ne devons pas
faire l'évangélisation
tout simplement
par obligation
pour décharger
une conscience
coupabilisée
de notre inertie
c'est d'avoir
le vrai amour
et voilà pourquoi
on doit mettre
en question
toute évangélisation
qui semble être
plus méthodique
qu'il est rationnel
et qu'organique
et dans ce cas
nous voyons
de manière très claire
qu'il est sensible
au Saint-Esprit
Philippe va croiser
les chemins
d'un homme
qui était véritablement
intéressé
dans la vérité
qui était véritablement
en train de chercher
Dieu
et une interaction
réelle
a lieu
et donc nous devons
être sensibles
à l'intérêt réel
des personnes
au moment de vie
qu'ils sont en train
de traverser
tout comme Jésus
avant de passer
directement à l'évangélisation
avec cette femme
samaritaine
il a échangé
pour démontrer
à cette femme
quels étaient
les points
de pression
sur son cœur
qui pointaient
envers
la nécessité
de l'évangile
donc c'est une interaction
réelle
sincèrement intéressée
où Philippe
donnera son temps
à cet homme
il va s'arrêter
il sortira
de sa routine
de son agenda
et cet homme
sera suffisamment
humble
pour poser des questions
avec un intérêt
réel
et donc
les marques
d'une évangélisation
biblique sont
cette interaction
réelle
sincèrement intéressée
ensuite
la conscience
de l'importance
d'un témoignage
authentique
d'un témoin authentique
c'est
crucial
que celui
qui
fasse
l'évangélisation
soit véritablement
converti
vous serrez
mes témoins
ce n'est pas
une question
de faire
c'est une question
d'être
et le plus
on est conscient
de la fraîcheur
de notre
contemplation
du Christ
et premièrement
le plus
authentique
et joyeux
sera le partage
de l'évangile
envers les personnes
et donc
Philippe
il est conscient
que même si cet homme
s'est approché
d'Israël
de la religion
juive
même si cet homme
avait cette copie
des textes
des haïts sur sa ment
la bible ouverte
il manquait encore
cette manière
que Dieu
a déterminée
de sauver
les perdus
à travers
les moyens
des témoins
de l'évangile
cet homme
seul
avec la bible ouverte
n'avait
aucune possibilité
de se sauver
ça ne dépendait pas
de lui
ça dépendait
d'un miracle
des miracles
de la régénération
pour la compréhension
salvatrice
des écritures
sauf que ces miracles
selon la détermination
des dieux
il a lieu
à travers
les témoignages
d'un évangéliste
d'un chrétien
qui partage
l'évangile
en autre
et donc Philippe
il était conscient
que c'était
de sa responsabilité
de proclamer
la parole
de Dieu
d'expliquer
l'évangile
à cet homme
afin que Dieu
fasse usage
de cette proclamation
et opère
sa régénération
et sa conversion
et donc
Philippe
il était présent
il a répondu
promptement
à la direction
des l'anges
car il savait
que pour la conversion
de cet homme
qui était
déterminé par Dieu
envers qui
Christ était déterminé
à sauver
cette conversion
aurait lieu
à travers
un témoin
de l'évangile
un chrétien
ce n'est pas pour dire
que c'est impossible
que Dieu sauve
certains
qui avec la Bible
mais c'est pour
reconnaître
que selon
l'ordre
général
établi
par Dieu
dans sa parole
comme l'apôtre Paul
dit
Dieu a décidé
de sauver
les perdus
par les moyens
de la folie
de la prédication
le scandale
donc
interaction réelle
conscience
de l'importance
d'un témoin authentique
et
troisième lieu
une évangélisation
biblique a lieu
lorsque Christ
est proclamé
avec puissance
ou la puissance
de l'esprit
selon la parole
de Dieu
c'est à dire
c'est une œuvre
trinitaire
à travers les saluts
de chaque être humain
c'est une œuvre
trinitaire
que Dieu a décidé
d'opérer
regarder les privilèges
que nous avons
à travers nos vies
à travers
nos vies
et particulièrement
lorsque nous
sommes fidèles
à la manière
des dieux
de sauver
à travers nos vies
l'efficacité
de l'évangélisation
et là je ne suis pas
en train de parler
des résultats
à salut
car l'évangélisation
est toujours
efficace
si biblique
que ce soit
pour exhaler
les bons parfums
du Christ
envers les saluts
que ce soit
pour exhaler
les parfums
des morts
pour redoubler
la condamnation
de ceux
qui vont réjeter
l'évangile
sauf que
la seule évangélisation
véritablement efficace
quel que soit
le résultat
c'est une évangélisation
qui est biblique
sinon
ce n'est pas
d'évangélisation
et l'évangélisation
biblique
c'est lorsque
Christ est proclamé
avec la puissance
du Saint-Esprit
selon la parole
de Dieu
et donc
l'autorité
cette sensation
d'authenticité
qui même
ceux qui rejettent
l'évangile
peuvent percevoir
c'est la même chose
que les juifs
ont dit
dans cette synagogue
où Jésus a prêché
et le public a dit
il ne prêche pas
comme les scribes
et les pharisiens
sa proclamation
n'est pas basée
tout simplement
sur les titres
la rhétorique
ou l'endumentaire
il prêche
ou il parle
avec autorité
c'est comme
David Hume
qui allait entendre
la prédication
d'Edward Huitfield
dans ses réveils
David Hume
un philosophe
sceptique
et son assistant
qui se demandait
pourquoi
tu vas entendre
cet homme
si tu ne crois pas
à ce qu'il dit
réponse de David Hume
car lui
il croit
en ce qu'il dit
donc nous ne pouvons
pas attendre
considérer
que notre évangélisation
est légitime
si nous n'avons pas
cette audace
cette hardiesse
que nous ne pouvons
pas confondre
avec l'agressivité
ce n'est pas
d'être rempli
de haine
ou de colère
comme les oppositeurs
vont vouloir
parfois nous tâcher
mais c'est
d'avoir
suffisamment
l'autorité
de Saint-Esprit
qui va générer
un tel amour
dans nos cœurs
que nous allons
dire des choses
parfois
dures à entendre
car nous aimons
les rebelles
mais toujours
en donnant de l'espoir
et c'est tout simplement
l'aspect
d'authenticité
indéniable
que nous trouvons
lorsqu'une personne
remplie de Saint-Esprit
est en train de proclamer
la parole
l'autorité
de l'Esprit
voilà pourquoi
le texte dit
que Philippe
bouche
grande ouverte
a commencé
à annoncer
Christ
à partir
de ses passages
dans les littérales
les versets 35
alors Philippe
ouvrant la bouche
ou avec la bouche
grande ouverte
ce qui veut signifier
cette hardiesse
cette conviction
cette authenticité
dans ses paroles
ça ne sonne pas
comme rhétorique
comme quelqu'un
qui présente
en Jésus
qui est en train
d'exprimer
une espèce
de carence
en soupliant
qu'on soit
en train d'adhérer
c'est le contraire
c'est la manifestation
de la sévérité
de la condition humaine
qui est sous la menace
inévitable
d'une condamnation
à cause de sa cul
de la responsabilité
et qui dans un message
revêtu d'autorité
nous exhorte
envers
la répentance
et la réconciliation
et donc c'est
l'autorité
de l'esprit
fondée
sur l'autorité
de la parole
des dieux
que l'esprit
lui-même
a inspiré
car les textes
ils parlent
de l'écriture
dans les sanguliers
même si cet homme
était en train
de lire
une portion
des haïs
Luc
il fait
de manière
très intentionnelle
de citer
qu'il s'agissait
d'une portion
de l'écriture
singulier
ce qui pointe
envers l'inspiration
de toute la Bible
la cohérence
interne
de toute la Bible
ce qui pointe
envers
cette
singularité
de ces
livres
et même si
ici il est en train
de se référer
à l'Ancien Testament
car les Nouveaux Testaments
étaient en train
de se développer encore
et malgré
la quantité
de livres
ils sont tous
appelés
écriture
car ils sont tous
l'objet
et les fruits
dans sa hauteur
c'est la présentation
de ce qu'on appelle
la Bible appelle
les oracles
des dieux
car c'est dieu lui-même
qui est dans l'écriture
et voilà pourquoi
le texte dit
commençant par
ces passages
lui annonça
Jésus-Christ
c'est-à-dire
il a pris
cet emploi
de l'écriture
et il a démontré
par plusieurs autres
passages
de l'écriture
comment cet homme
devrait interpréter
ces passages
de l'écriture
Philippe n'est pas
en train de présenter
son opinion
à propos de Jésus
Philippe est en train
de proclamer
Christ
selon l'écriture
voilà
les prochains aspects
lorsqu'ils nous devront
proclamer Christ
avec la puissance
du Saint-Esprit
selon la parole
des dieux
c'est car
l'écriture
a
un centre
principal
et c'est Christ
c'est centré
sur Christ
l'évangélisation
donc commençant
par ces passages
je annonça
la bonne nouvelle
de Jésus-Christ
et
il faut que ça soit
doctrinaire
car la conception
elle-même
d'oracle
c'est
de nous aider
à comprendre
que la Bible
a une seule
interprétation
et l'intentionnalité
de Dieu
c'était de nous révéler
surtout
la signification
de l'œuvre
et la personne
de Jésus-Christ
notre sauveur
comment nous réconcilier
avec Dieu
c'est très erroné
de partir envers la Bible
pour
être toujours
en train de chercher
des réponses
très superficielles
à nos problèmes
quotidiens
Dieu dans sa grâce
les fait
il y a plein de principes
dans la Bible
qui s'appliquent
à l'ensemble de la vie
mais
les messages principaux
dans tous les passages
des écritures
c'est de nous pointer
envers
les seigneurs
Jésus-Christ
pour régler
les problèmes
radicals
de nos vies
et donc
il faut que ça soit
doctrinaire
car les principaux
événements
et les principaux
éléments
liés
à l'identité
du Christ
sont
absolument
nécessaires
et cruciales
pour les saluts
de tous les êtres
humains
une compréhension
de qui
Jésus-Christ
qui ne soit pas
précisément
biblique
ou une compréhension
de l'œuvre
du Christ
qui ne soit pas
précisément
biblique
rend impossible
les saluts
la vraie
réconciliation
je ne peux pas
avoir mon idée
de Christ
je ne peux pas
choisir
certains prédicateurs
en me disant
je pense qu'il est
en train de présenter
un Christ
qui je ne peux pas
accepter
si cette personne
est en train
de présenter
les Christs
bibliques
on n'a pas de choix
mais bien sûr
que nous savons
qu'aujourd'hui
il y a beaucoup
de personnes
qui ne présentent
pas les Christs
bibliques
qu'est-ce que
l'apôtre Paul
va dire
qu'il soit
en Athènes
et donc ici
quelles sont
les vérités principales
qui sont
explicites
en Esaïe 53
et que Philippe
était capable
de présenter
à cet homme
afin de les conduire
à sa lutte
c'est qu'il était
confirmé par sa réponse
plus tard
en disant
je crois
que Jésus-Christ
est véritablement
le fils des dieux
donc
quand on lit
les passages
qu'il était
en train de lire
qui étaient expliqués
par Esaïe
verset 32
les passages
de l'écriture
qu'il lisait
étaient celles-ci
il a été mené
comme une brébie
à la boucherie
donc cela
démontre
la notion
de la Pâque
réveillant
à la notion
des sacrifices
du temple
et ça parle
d'une justice
substitutive
car il y a
l'innocence
de ses substituts
et il y a aussi
surtout la notion
d'expiation
car il sera
immolé
bien sûr
que
on est dans une période
où ces prosélytes
ok
ces éthiopiens
qui part
envers Jérusalem
pour adorer
il a déjà
une compréhension
de ces choses
et en plus
c'est après
la crucifixion
du Christ
qui a eu lieu
exactement
pendant la Pâque
et donc
Philippe va lier
les points
et va démontrer
comment les Christs
étaient les vrais
âmes de Dieu
qui enlèvent
les péchés du monde
qui offrent
et donc
si nous ne croyons pas
à la justice
substitutive
du Christ
il n'y a pas de salut
Christ n'est pas mort
à la croix
comme une expression
tout simplement
de l'injustice humaine
ou comme un exemple
de ne pas réagir
à l'injustice
il était en train
de vivre
à la croix
véritablement
la punition
qu'on méritait
pour présenter à Dieu
une innocence
qu'on n'a pas
et comme un agneau
moué
devant celui que l'étant
il n'a pas
envers la bouche
Philippe va lier
les points
et va expliquer
la doctrine
de la justification
volontaire
il y a une hérésie
aujourd'hui
qui dit
que Jésus
était en train
de payer
à Satan
un prix
pour qu'il
soit racheté
comme s'il
devrait faire
un sacrifice
à Dieu
en abus
d'autorité
parentale
Dieu
il est si sévère
et si méchant
que pour nous pardonner
il a dû punir
son propre fils
et la Bible
nous présente
l'aspect volontaire
à chaque fois
tant
dans Dieu
qui souffre
lorsqu'il va
son fils
souffrir
Dieu a tant aimé
les mondes
qu'il a envoyé
son fils
et un fils
il va volontairement
donner
personne n'est
autre ma vie
moi-même
je la donne
et donc ici
cet aspect
volontairement
moué
en pouvant
comme lui-même
l'a dit
quand il a été
attrapé
je pourrais
appeler
des myriades
d'anges
pour me délivrer
mais il va
mouer
pour représenter
cet aspect
volontaire
nécessaire
pour notre salut
l'écrit
s'il a volontairement
s'est mis
à disposition
pour assumer
notre place
afin de nous
créditer
sa justice
et recevoir
sur lui
notre punition
donc cette justice
volontaire
et c'est 33
dans son humiliation
son jugement
a été élevé
et ici
c'est pour redoubler
la conviction
de cette justice
substitutive
si l'agneau
représente plus
l'expiation
l'immolation
ou la punition
de nos péchés
la reconnaissance
qu'il était puni
injustement
par la perspective humaine
veut pointer
envers sa droiture
parfaite
l'expression
justice ici
pointe envers
la notion
d'une obéissance
même légale
parfaite
représentative
il n'a pas pu
faire recours
à la vraie justice
voilà pourquoi
la Bible nous dit
qu'il est saint
Jésus Christ
il est né
d'une femme
et il est né
sous la loi
cette loi
interne
présente
dans toutes les consciences
de tous les êtres humains
Dieu l'a externalisée
et cela faisait partie aussi
d'établir
une espèce
d'ordre
légal
qui pourrait devenir
réel
et cosmique
dans les temps
dans l'espace
voilà pourquoi
la croix
est un moment
d'exécution
pénale
par la perspective
divine
il a plu
à Dieu
même passage
des essences
de l'écraser
car il était
en train
de porter
sur lui
nos péchés
et donc
quand on voit
la croix
et l'explication
la plus probable
de Philippe
par rapport à ça
il est en train
de démontrer
son jugement
a été
lévé
et voici
ce qu'il dit
Esaïe
et sa génération
qui la dépendra
car sa vie
a été
étrangée
de la terre
et donc
nous devons croire
à la mort
littérale
du Seigneur
Jésus Christ
à la mort
littérale
du Messie
car pour certains
qui veulent mettre
en question
la résurrection
comme il voit
des évidences
indéniables
du fait
que Christ
a été vivant
après
la crucifixion
ils veulent nier
plutôt que Christ
soit véritablement mort
mais ici
il y a la notion
de la mort littérale
et avec ça
la notion inévitable
de la résurrection
car ces mots
ou ces termes
génération
surtout quand on considère
les contextes
plus larges
des Esaïes
nous parlent
d'un terme
qui veut
signifier
deux choses
car les contextes
touchent à ces deux choses
qui était capable
de vérifier
dans toutes les généalogies
promises
quelle était
la génération
la descendance
quelle était
l'origine
du Christ
et voilà pourquoi
Matthieu
et Luc
commencent
leur évangile
en nous présentant
la généalogie
du Christ
pour nous montrer
et nous prouver
qu'il était exactement
les Messies
promis
mais ça parle aussi
de sa postérité
le fait
qu'il part
comme Esaïe
se controidit
par sa mort
et son humiliation
l'éternel
l'exaucera
!
il serait ressuscité
et sa postérité
prospèrera
l'Église
la croissance
de son royaume
et donc ici
nous voyons
ces doctrines
que personne
ne peut être sauvé
s'il ne croit pas
que Christ a été
possédé
à une double nature
une nature divine
pour pouvoir
une dignité
capable
de couvrir
la multitude
des péchés
d'une multitude
de personnes
sa valeur
sa dignité
mais aussi
sa capacité
de ne pas être
contaminé
par les péchés
c'est nécessaire
qu'il soit généré
par le Saint-Esprit
sur les ventres
de Marie
sans la contamination
de la chair humaine
pour éviter
la transmission
de la corruption
de péché
afin qu'il soit
capable d'être
à la une
un vrai homme
pour nous représenter
en tant qu'hommes
et sans contamination
pour accomplir
une obéissance
parfaite
à notre place
et donc sa génération
qui a osé
la reconnaître
la vérifier
la déchiffrer
car sa vie
a été
rétranchée
de la terre
et toutes les promesses
à propos
du Messie
ou un grand nombre
des promesses
surtout celles
auxquelles
ils étaient
les plus attachés
les aïe
sont explicites
en parlant
de sa mort
son humiliation
et son jugement
injuste
et c'est intéressant
de remarquer
que quand on
contemple
les promesses
auxquelles
les juifs
ils étaient
accrochés
dans l'attente
dans le Messie
c'était plutôt
les fils de l'homme
de Daniel
qui viendraient
pour régner
et prospérer
sur terre
prospérité
temporelle
terrestre
d'Israël
et la réalité
c'est que Christ
mourant
de cette manière
scandaleuse
devient
un grand blocage
à ceux
qui étaient
très accrochés
à ce monde
personne ne voulait
reconnaître
qu'il était
le vrai fils
des dieux
des Messies
par contre
Philippe
il explique
cette doctrine
de la mort réelle
l'escandale
de la croix
et la doublature
de Christ
et donc
c'est une évangélisation
remplie de l'esprit
selon la parole
centrée sur Christ
doctrinaire
mais profondément
relationnelle
avec Jésus
cette évangélisation
selon l'expression
Philippe
lui
évangélise à Christ
c'est un peu
similaire
à cette notion
de Paul
quand il dit
au Galacte
je vous ai
placardé
Christ
comme crucifié
pendant que
toutes ces explications
puissantes
remplies de son esprit
étaient en train
de se donner
à travers
Philippe
l'objectif
de Philippe
et la concrétisation
du salut
de l'Eunuque
c'est comme
Paul décrit
sa propre conversion
pour plus
que Christ
ressuscité
apparaisse
à Paul
il dit
qu'il a plu
à celui
qui m'a mis à part
dès l'éventé ma mère
de révéler son fils
au-dedans
des mois
et donc
à travers la prédication
c'est que
l'Eunuque
a contemplé
c'était Christ
lui-même
qui s'est présenté
de manière concrète
et réelle
et spirituelle
pour son salut
donc une évolution
biblique
elle n'est pas
très préoccupée
tout simplement
avec des explications
théoriques
à propos
de la théologie
l'intérêt intellectuel
envers la théologie
c'est comme
l'adjuste disait
si vous commencez
à noter
quand je commence
à prêcher
c'est pas un problème
mais si jusqu'à la fin
vous n'avez pas
laissé tomber
votre stylo
pour regarder
les prédicateurs
j'ai la sensation
que j'ai échoué
et voilà pourquoi
il y a
certaines
certaines occasions
où c'est très légitime
d'utiliser
les diapos
mais
il faut qu'on se rappelle
que la prédication
il s'agit de l'interaction
entre Dieu
et l'homme
à travers
la bouche
d'un prédicateur
d'un évangéliste
donc l'évangélisation
est véritablement efficace
lorsqu'il Christ
se manifeste
par un témoignage
emprunt de l'autorité
de l'esprit
et transmis
à travers
la proclamation
de la parole
de Dieu
et quels sont les résultats
quatrième point
pour nous
c'est
comme Philippe
nous devons agir
en tant qu'ambassadeur
responsable
dans l'expansion
du roi du Christ
ici nous sommes
devant
les baptêmes
la consommation
de la foi
et les baptêmes
de l'éronique
on est devant
les résultats
positifs
d'une évangélisation
biblique
et efficace
quelqu'un
qui est
évidemment
converti
et cette conversion
authentique
elle se révèle
par plusieurs facteurs
et signes
ici dans la parole
des dieux
malheureusement
comme
les textes
hors contexte
et prétexte
des résines
nous sommes
en train
de voir
aujourd'hui
l'abus
de ces textes
par ce qu'on appelle
des baptêmes
spontanés
par ce qu'on appelle
des mouvements
d'évangélisation
déconnectés
des églises locales
car quelques aspects
exceptionnels
de la conversion
des léoniques
sont mis en lumière
en détriment
de ce qui est la règle
pour l'église
et j'espère
que j'espère
qu'on puisse voir
de manière très évidente
la bonne manière
d'interpréter
ces textes
et donc
il faut qu'on reconnaisse
les liens
entre
une évangélisation
responsable
et des conversions
authentiques
une évangélisation
responsable
et une église
composée
par des régénérés
par des croyants
la mauvaise
réputation
de l'église
la plupart des temps
est liée
à la fausse conversion
des chrétiens
nominaux
et quand on revient
à Matthieu 16
Jésus va instituer
les paramètres
pour l'église
et il fera exprès
!
d'évaluer
la profession
des fois
de ses propres
disciples
et laisser par là
les paramètres
pour l'église
de ce qu'on doit faire
avant de les confirmer
par les baptêmes
l'église
n'est sera jamais
inhérente
Philippe lui-même
a participé
responsablement
de l'évangélisation
du magicien
qui n'était pas
vraiment converti
mais si
l'inévitable
est une réalité
c'est clair
que ce n'est pas
une chose
qu'on doit s'aimer
il n'existe pas
une porte large
envers la conversion
et nous voyons
que quand l'église
travaille de manière
responsable
la bonne majorité
des saints
membres
étaient
qui sera formé
des vrais chrétiens
comme c'était
le cas en Samarie
et donc pour revenir
à ce texte
comment nous pouvons
être des ambassadeurs
responsables
quand on fait
l'évangélisation
et le Christ
lui-même
nous a enseigné
en Matthieu 28
que l'évangélisation
n'est pas
déconnectée
de l'église
que l'évangélisation
est connectée
au baptême
et que l'évangélisation
concerne
non seulement
l'acte
de partager l'évangile
mais d'introduire
les nouveaux-nés
dans la famille
de la foi
afin de continuer
de les discipler
baptisez-leur
au nom du Père
du Fils et du Saint-Esprit
et enseignez-leur
à garder
tous mes commandements
c'est une seule commission
avec tous ces éléments
et donc
la première chose
qu'on doit faire
c'est de chercher
à identifier
chez
les professants
les signes
des conversions authentiques
et donc c'est intéressant
nous voyons plusieurs signes
dans la question
de l'Eunuque
et voilà pourquoi
nous ne sommes pas ici
devant
un baptême
envers l'évangélisation
de l'Eunuque
c'est un baptême
qui confirme
la foi de l'Eunuque
et un baptême
qui peut confirmer
la foi de l'Eunuque
car Philippe
a agi responsablement
devant les signes
des conversions
de cet homme
donc ici nous voyons
de manière très intéressante
la manifestation
d'un profond désir
de trouver la vérité
du salut
c'est la première chose
qu'on voit dans les passages
c'est des indices
qui en général
donne beaucoup
d'espoir
à celui
qui est en train
d'évangéliser
ce sont des signes
qu'on peut
sentir
comme s'il s'agissait
les signes
d'élection
c'est ce travail
des dieux
dans la vie d'un homme
qui commence
à traverser
des changements
radicaux
dans sa vie
dans une recherche
sincère
des dieux
cet homme
il était
débasé
troublé
il était un homme
de grande importance
très élevé
dans sa société
secrétaire
presque gouverneur
il était un peu
comme les Joseph
d'Egypte
mais pour l'Ethiopie
il plaidait
une allégeance
suprême
à la reine
étant
eunuque
lui-même
castré
il avait
marqué
son corps
avec un symbole
d'allégeance
à ses royaumes
sauf qu'il n'était
pas satisfait
intellectuellement
il posait
encore des questions
par rapport
à la signification
de la vie
et tout ça
il était insatisfait
aussi moralement
quand on lit
dans l'histoire
la manière
dont ces personnes
profitaient de la vie
vivaient leur vie
dans la cour
il y a beaucoup
d'immoralité
beaucoup de plaisir
et ce n'était pas
suffisant pour lui
et même religieusement
cet homme
n'était pas satisfait
car il était
devenu
un prosélyte
d'Israël
en ayant
été d'abord
déçu
avec les religions
présentées
dans son empire
les paganismes
qui traitaient
les rois
comme une divinité
et c'est très intéressant
de remarquer
que
jusque là
il jouait encore
dans un terrain
assez sécurisé
car il y a
une longue relation
entre l'Ethiopie
et Israël
dans l'histoire
de la Bible
et
les plus
probablement
surtout avec
la diaspora
c'était une religion
tolérée
encore
dans l'Ethiopie
mais cet homme
il était en train
d'avoir de la peine
pour trouver une réponse
il s'est donné
le travail
même sachant
qu'il ne serait
jamais inclus
dans les cercles
les plus antérieurs
à cause de sa condition
physique
ni à cause
de sa position
en tant que prosélyte
il serait toujours
à la marge
de la pratique
religieuse judaïque
et en plus
c'était un contexte
des corruptions judaïques
dans lesquelles
la plus grande
certitude
qu'on aurait
c'est que
si Christ
ne serait jamais
parlé
ça serait
d'une manière
complètement mauvaise
il n'était pas
reconnu
en tant que messie
à cause de la manière
dont il est mort
voilà pourquoi
ce texte est très
très important
pour sa conversion
cet homme
s'est donné la peine
c'est un homme
très intelligent
d'examiner
il ne voulait pas
dépendre
de l'enseignement
des juifs
mais c'était
quand même
sécurisé pour lui
car
si sa vie
était très promiscue
avec des divinités
ou des philosophies
qui voulaient plutôt
légitimiter la promiscuité
comme on a encore
aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs
les philosophies
les plus progressistes
et relativistes
sont celles
qui cherchent
à légitimiser
les plus
la promiscuité
comme a dit
Tinkler
dans son adolescence
l'attrait qu'il a eu
à un moment donné
pour ça
il disait
c'est revêtir
d'une cape
comme si on était
en train de sortir
à la défense
des pauvres
enlever des riches
pour donner aux pauvres
et pouvoir
s'écoucher
avec n'importe qui
c'est la manière
dont il a résumé
l'enfance
qu'il recevait
dans son adolescence
mais cet homme
a pu avoir
une soif
et c'est quelque chose
qui est récourante
d'ailleurs
les jeunes
parfois
qui se sont donnés
les plus
au manque
des règles
et des normes
dans leur philosophie
dans leur éducation
sont parfois
ceux qui sont
les plus radicalisés
quand ils s'approchent
des religions
les plus légalistes
et il était
en train de jouer
d'une manière
un peu assez sécurisée
je l'ai dit
car nous voyons ça
encore aujourd'hui
pourquoi après
la dilution
chez les évangéliques
chez les réformés
d'une préoccupation
légitime
avec la sainteté
pourquoi
dans une génération
où nous ne voyons
presque aucune différence
entre une soirée
dans une boîte
des nuits
et certains cultes
qu'on peut présenter
nous voyons
cet élan
qui revient
après toute cette division
dans l'église
cet élan
qui revient même
à embrasser
le catholicisme
légaliste
de nos jours
la vraie foi
!
nous confronte
personnellement
avec le Seigneur
Jésus Christ
et c'est très sécurisé
de vouloir
déléguer
l'assurance
de notre salut
plutôt à des choses
que nous pouvons faire
faire la répentance
déléguer
l'assurance
de notre salut
à la vie
d'un prêtre
au lieu de savoir
que nous sommes
véritablement répentis
et affectueusement
connectés personnellement
au Seigneur Jésus
c'est une religion
qui restait
très légaliste
très externe
une religion
basée sur les fers
et attachée
à ces mondes
c'était une institution
respectable
voilà pourquoi
tolérable
qui faisait partie même
de l'histoire
de la tradition
entre les bonnes relations
entre l'Ethiopie
tout comme les catholicismes
restent en France
la bonne tradition
ce qui reste
de nos valeurs
moraux
ce n'était pas suffisant
pour la conversion
de cet homme
et il sortait
de la Pentecôte
il a fait exprès
de prendre
les schémas
les plus solitaires
il s'est donné la peine
d'acheter une copie
des Aïs
sa capacité
de comprendre
la Vulgate
la traduction
de la Bible
juive
envers la diaspora
pour faciliter
la compréhension
et cet homme
était en train
d'analyser
d'étudier
de soi-même
par soi-même
la parole de Dieu
et tout ce qu'il n'a pas
pu trouver toute seule
ni dans la religion
ni dans ses études
ni dans la philosophie
ni dans la cour
ni dans les plaisirs
de la vie
était disponible
dans un homme simple
comme Philippe
qui a croisé
Sacha
les chrétiens authentiques
les plus simples
utilisés par Dieu
à la capacité
indépendamment
de ses compréhensions
culturelles
d'annoncer
Christ
selon les écritures
pour les saluts
des perdus
cet homme
il était véritablement
à la recherche
de Dieu
cet homme aussi
était en train
de manifester
un désir profond
surtout après avoir
entendu l'évangile
d'embrasser
Christ
comme Seigneur
et Sauveur
Philippe
il a instruit
il a déclaré
il a peut-être
même souplié
comme fait l'apôtre Paul
on vous en souplie
réconciliez-vous
avec Dieu
mais réconciliez-vous
c'est pas moi
de vous prendre
et de vous plonger
dans l'eau
c'est pas moi
d'appeler
Thiago
pour qu'il joue
le piano
pendant que j'amène
les messages
vers la fin
afin de toucher
vos affections
c'est pas moi
de vous faire répéter
une prière
ou une profession
de foi
si ça n'a pas
comme point de départ
votre expérience
authentique
et légitime
avec Christ
au-dedans
de vos cœurs
Philippe a présenté
les scandales
de la croix
il n'a pas fait
aux âges
des artifices
de dissimulation
d'émotionalisme
superficiel
Jésus lui-même
quand les multitudes
partent
après la multiplication
des points et façons
et elles reviennent
et il leur dit
vous êtes là
car je vous ai donné
à manger
vous n'êtes pas là
à cause de mon message
et tous partent
ils se tournent
envers ses disciples
et quelle est la question
qu'ils posent
et vous aussi
vous voulez vous en aller
où allons-nous
si ce n'est que toi
qui as les paroles
de vie éternelle
le cœur
qui n'a pas
cette conviction
n'est pas un cœur converti
qui Christ
pour les sauver
est toujours
irrésistible
et donc
les désirs
il part
de l'éluque
lui-même
voici l'eau
qu'est-ce qui empêche
que je sois baptisé
vous comprenez
c'est les réproches
que Lloyd-Jones
faisait à Billy Grant
qui était un grand évangéliste
un homme très capable
envers qui on doit être
très reconnaissant
envers Dieu
que ça soit pas mal compris
par contre
qui faisait un usage
très lourd
des éléments
émotionnalistes
une évaluation
par rapport
au fruit
de son ministère
car c'est facile
de compter
les nombres
des conversions
si on va compter
tout simplement
les personnes
qui viennent
des vents
mais c'est pas comme ça
qu'on compte
les nombres
des vraies conversions
la plupart
n'étaient pas connectés
à des églises
la plupart
n'ont pas fini
leur vie
professant la vraie foi
!
Lloyd-Jones avait toujours
trois remarques
mais je vais mentionner
juste deux
à cause du temps
de ne pas partager
les poupitres
avec des sectes
et ce qu'il a voulu dire
par là
il disait
de ne jamais
suggérer au public
qu'ils peuvent arriver
au salut
avec quelque chose
de plus que Jésus
donc voilà les catholiques
qui prêchaient parfois
à côté des Billy Grant
ni avec quelque chose
de moins
que Jésus
c'est qui les rabbis
représentaient
lorsqu'il faisait partie
des croisades
de Billy Grant
les messages communiqués
au public
par cette association
c'était un message
qui pourrait amener
à la perdition
c'était presque
une validation
de ces deux courants
ces deux sectes
car jusqu'à ce qu'on
ne reconnaît pas
l'absolue nécessité
du Christ
comme le Fils des Dieu
pour notre salut
et la totale suffisance
exclusivement du Christ
pour notre salut
on n'a pas compris
l'évangile
et l'autre
c'était notamment
l'usage
de l'appel
à l'autel
qui s'est joué
de manière
très émotionnaliste
et automatique
alors bien sûr
on n'a pas besoin
d'être complètement
opposé
à exhorter
les personnes
mais dans le cas
de Billy Grand
il y a eu un jour
où
dans une de ses croisades
il a dû s'arrêter
car c'était télévisionné
et il y a eu
une espèce
de publicité
dans la télé
et ils ont dû
faire un intervalle
entre la fin
de son message
et les chants
qu'il jouait
pour jouer
avec ses exhortations
et appellent l'autel
et rien que cette pause
qui a coupé
cet émotionnalisme
a produit
un résultat
surprenant
différent
de la majorité
de ces croisades
où
tout cet émotionnalisme
jouait ensemble
les nombres
des personnes
qui sont venues
étaient infiniment inférieurs
ce qui nous fait
poser les questions
sur
qu'est-ce qui représenterait
vraiment
l'efficacité
de cette évangélisation
John lui-même
partage
les jours
où il était
en train de prêcher
un homme qui pleurait
pendant
tous les sermons
et il a senti
l'envie
de venir vers lui
et de l'encourager
envers
une décision
biblique
envers l'évangile
sauf qu'il avait
tellement de monde
et il n'arrive pas
à cet homme
à la fin du culte
et il était
un peu attristé
déçu
frustré
mais il a croisé
cet homme
les vendredis
il est venu vers lui
il dit
j'ai eu envie
j'étais vu là
touché
brisé
je voulais venir
vers toi
ces jours-là
réponse
Deloitte
je suis content
pardon
et cet homme l'a dit
si tu l'aurais fait
j'aurais rendu
ma vie à Christ
réponse Deloitte
si ton intérêt
pour Christ
n'a pas duré
une semaine
je suis content
de ne pas l'avoir fait
car ce n'est pas
signe
d'une conversion authentique
ça part tout simplement
de cet homme
qui a eu une rencontre
avec Christ
au-dedans de soi
à travers la prédication
d'un autre
et il veut
s'éfer baptiser
c'est un désir
volontaire
non seulement
d'embrasser Christ
comme son Seigneur
et Sauveur
mais c'est un désir
volontaire
d'officialiser
publiquement
cette association
il veut être
reconnu
par un représentant
légal
de l'Église
du Christ
comme quelqu'un
qui est en train
de plaider
son allégance
publique
au Seigneur
Jésus-Christ
c'est ça la signification
de l'Église
du baptême
lié sur terre
lié au ciel
délié sur terre
des liés au ciel
c'est une ambassade
céleste sur terre
autorisée par Christ
voilà pourquoi
déjà l'importance
d'être très sûr
que nous sommes
devant une ambassade
autorisée par Christ
car moi je ne peux pas
commencer à faire
des schisbourgers
et mettre
une plaque
de McDonald's
je ne peux pas
utiliser le nom
du Christ
parler du Christ
mais présenter
des vérités
complètement opposées
à ce que
Jésus-Christ
mais ce désir
c'était un désir
volontaire
de la part
de l'Eunuque
déjà
lui voulait
se faire baptiser
il voulait
consommer
son salut
et ça c'est important
qu'on soit au clair
par rapport à ça
les baptêmes
n'ont aucune
capacité
de soi-même
pour sauver
personne
que ça soit clair
les baptêmes
ne sauvent pas
il n'en perd pas
de soi-même
par contre
il a été
institué
par Christ
comme une expression
des complitudes
il n'est pas
une étape
quelque part
séparée
de la conversion
c'est lui
qui va
officialiser
la conversion
et pourquoi
c'est important
de considérer ça
car pour plus
que ceux
qui sont
véritablement convertis
même sans les baptêmes
sont sauvés
comme les voleurs
à la croix
nous devons nous rappeler
que pour plus
que nous soyons
des âmes vivantes
Dieu nous a créés
avec un corps
et Dieu
a déterminé
cette visibilité
concrète
de l'évangile
voilà pourquoi
l'évangile
est composé
des faits historiques
voilà pourquoi
la croix
n'était pas
tout simplement
une croix
abstraite
c'était une incarnation
littérale
c'est un roi
littéral
qui garde son corps
ressuscité
glorifié
pour être
les rois
pour toujours
Dieu a
externalisé
quelque part
toutes nos crises
de conscience
et morale
car il nous a fait
son image
pour représenter
aussi
son image
de manière concrète
et visuelle
et la loi externe
les dix commandements
et toutes les lois
de cérémonie
nous préparaient
pour comprendre
que Dieu
allait accomplir
ses jugements
spirituels
émotionnels
et physiques
corps
âme
esprit
et voilà pourquoi
son église
est visible
c'est pas l'église
avec un nier majuscule
invisible
on parle de l'église
dans le sens où
nous sommes en train
de penser
à l'ensemble
des églises
mais l'église
invisible
véritable
est toujours
en train de s'exprimer
dans un corps
réel
et visible
voilà pourquoi
l'alliance
est institutionnelle
par les baptêmes
et par la sainte sainte
voilà pourquoi
la membriété
de l'église
est significative
voilà pourquoi
mon association
à Jésus Christ
Jésus lui-même
l'a dit
c'est lui
qui ne m'est ni
devant les hommes
ni devant Dieu
et la manière
dont Christ lui-même
a établi
pour que nous puissions
formaliser
ça me gêne un peu
l'exemple qu'on donne
parfois
du mariage
c'est réel
quelque part
mais c'est encore faible
pas dans les sens glorieux
du réel mariage
entre Christ et l'église
j'ai dit
par rapport
au baptême
des fois on dit
on a déjà
une relation d'amour
et on va juste formaliser
c'est pas qu'il est juste
formalisé
dans les cas de baptême
ça fait partie
d'une espèce
de complitude
d'officialisation
d'une relation
avec un royaume
réel
qui se manifeste
de manière visible
sur terre
à travers son église
réelle
légitime
et autorisée
et donc ça emploie
d'importance énorme
et je suis content
que l'Eunuque
soit beaucoup plus
préparé à comprendre ça
que nous-mêmes
car lui
il était membre
d'un empire
et un membre
très important
d'un empire
et il a entendu parler
de ces messies
qui ont été crucifiés
avec cette plaque
roi des juifs
et Christ
nous est présenté
partout
comme ça
et Esaïe 53
fait la liaison
entre son humiliation
et
les déclenchements
de son royaume
davidique
Jésus
le vrai David
et c'est la réalité
pour nous
nous sommes
membres
d'un royaume
nous sommes
ambassadeurs
du Christ
et nous ne pouvons
pas désister
de la vraie église
de la vraie ambassade
ou des vraies ambassades
car nous sommes
en train de voir
beaucoup d'abus
beaucoup de corruption
dans les églises
et donc il y a
cet aspect
officiel
que nous voyons
et les désirs
de cet homme
de cet individu
de se faire
reconnaître
de plaider
son allégeance
à Christ
et d'être scellé
par son baptême
il y a aussi
la manifestation
authentique
de la foi
au niveau du coeur
car Philippe
comme
un ambassadeur
responsable
va poser la question
si tu crois
de tout ton coeur
tu les peux
mais regardez bien
qui donne la réponse
est-ce que Philippe
est en train de dire
si tu crois
de tout ton coeur
répète ça
avec moi
si tu crois
de tout ton coeur
question du Christ
qui les hommes
disent
qui je suis
et vous
qui vous dites
qui je suis
réponse de Pierre
très similaire
et c'est comme ça
qu'on fait
pour aider
les personnes
qui veulent
se faire baptiser
ou joindre l'église
on pose la question
de manière très simple
elles peuvent avoir
12-13 ans
50 ans
leurs réponses
peuvent être simples
pas théologiquement
très profondes
ou très précises
est toujours
suffisante
pour démontrer
une relation réelle
avec Christ
fils des dieux
sauveur
donc il donne
cette réponse positive
qui révèle
la foi
au profond
de son coeur
et qui est aussi
une manifestation
d'une profession
des fois
publique
qui sera attachée
à son baptême
cette foi
a pour évidence
aussi
les implications
pour son baptême
et
nous on était
en train d'échanger
entre les
les pasteurs
de cette église
combien
les implications
des joueurs
dans les ministères
se sont en plan
représentent
quelque part
une position
des risques
qu'aucune profession
n'a
parfois même pas
la profession
des présidents
car c'est la seule
dont la conduite morale
est profondément
attachée
à la qualification
pour les ministères
et nous savons
que nous sommes
tous imparfaits
et pour ceux
qui comme Lloyd-Jones
ont laissé même
une carrière brillante
des médecins
pour embrasser
la pelle
à temps plein
pour le ministère
si jamais
il tomberait
dans un péché grave
il perdrait
même l'opportunité
qu'il avait eue avant
le problème
c'est que
selon les paramètres
du nouveau testament
c'est pas
que les pasteurs
qui peuvent
prendre ces risques
tout chrétien
qui veut professer
leur foi
publiquement
dans un monde
méchant
le plus notre témoin
du Christ
est visible
est audible
le plus notre conduite
va contre
ce monde
le plus exposé
à la persécution
on sera
et nous sommes tous
en train de risquer
les promotions
à l'emploi
les boulots
lui-même
dans les cas
de cet homme
de plaider
son allégeance
à Christ
était complètement différent
d'adhérer
la foi juif
Christ
le Seigneur
la foi
la plus persécutée
une allégeance
tellement radicale
à Jésus
pourrait coûter
à l'Eunuque
la perte
de toute sa position
en Éthiopie
sauf qu'il comparait
la reine
de Candace
à Jésus Christ
fils de Dieu
il n'a aucune doute
comme la dion
nous a dit
je ne considère
avoir rien
renoncé
c'est le plus
grand privilège
la plus grande promotion
être appelé au ministère
et donc cet homme
manifeste
par son désir
de plaider
sa foi publiquement
et s'associer
officiellement à Christ
par les baptêmes
il démontre aussi
tous ses risques
tout comme Pierre
c'est la même chose
quand Pierre dit
tu as les Christ
les fils des dieux vivants
les fils des dieux
il est en train
d'aller contre
toutes les pressions
culturelles
et religieuses
de son époque
un autre élément
c'est la joie
qu'il expérimente
une fois
qu'il est baptême
et consommer
et c'est 39
quand ils furent
sortis de l'eau
l'esprit du seigneur
enlève à Philippe
et l'éluque
ne les vit plus
et donc c'est clair
pardon
l'éluque
il n'est plus
tandis qu'il joyeux
il poursuivait sa route
et donc il y avait
cette joie
envers les baptêmes
qui a été consommée
par les baptêmes
cette joie
qui doit faire partie
de toute
explication
authentique
des conversions
tout témoignage
authentique des conversions
finalement cet homme
a trouvé la satisfaction
intellectuelle
morale
spirituelle
et nous voyons aussi
que nous n'avons
aucun droit
quand on contemple
la manière responsable
dont Philippe
a rassemblé
ses évidences
pour pouvoir
en tant que représentant
de l'église
de Jérusalem
baptiser cet homme
voilà les trois éléments
qui composent
un baptême légitime
à foi
réelle
car nous voyons ça
une
un représentant
officiel
ou formel
d'une église
formelle
et donc une église
qui pratique ses baptêmes
un baptême
qui doit être toujours
public
c'était le cas
même si au désert
et qui représente
toujours la connexion
entre les baptisés
et l'église
mais par une étape
c'est la porte d'entrée
envers les peuples de Dieu
car Christ
les rois
est les rois
d'un royaume
et les rois d'un peuple
il n'est pas les rois
des individus
les pères
n'est père
des pères
qui est des individus
il est père
de ses enfants
et nous voyons
de manière très claire
que
c'est nouveau-né
devient un ambassadeur
lui-même
par la confirmation
de cet homme
c'était exceptionnel
bien sûr
c'était au désert
mais c'était public
il n'y avait pas
d'église en Éthiopie
mais cet homme
est reconnu dans l'histoire
comme les patrons
de l'église de l'Éthiopie
il avait compris
sa mission
je suis maintenant
le représentant missionnaire
de Jérusalem
à
en Éthiopie
nous ne pouvons pas imaginer
qu'après cette expérience
il sorte
en se disant
je suis un électron libre
maintenant
déconnecté complètement
de l'église
il était l'objet
de l'évangélisation
d'un missionnaire
reconnu par l'église
donc les mains
ont été imposées sur lui
qualifiées pour le faire
et donc la vraie évangélisation
et la vraie conversion
sont marquées
par ces éléments
d'évidence
des conversions authentiques
des responsabilités
dans la manière
dont on accueille
les membres
de la famille de Dieu
pour que l'église continue
à avoir cette efficacité
dans sa représentation
et dans sa progression
et c'est ça qu'on voit
dans la suite
juste pour lire
la fin de ces passages
où Philippe
va continuer
son chemin
je vais juste vous citer
l'énoncé du point
c'est Philippe
comme Philippe
nous devons persévérer
avec joie
dans nos contributions
à l'avancée irrésistive
du roi du Christ
et c'est 38
pardon
et c'est 39
quand il fut sorti
de l'eau
l'esprit du Seigneur
enlèva Philippe
et le nuque
ne lévit plus
tandis que joyeux
il poursuivait sa route
Philippe se trouva
en Azote
d'où il alla
jusqu'à Césarée
en évangélisant
toutes les villes
par lesquelles il passait
les chrétiens
les témoins du Christ
où il passe
il prêche
ça devrait être
et avec joie
car il était en train
de partager
la bonne nouvelle
par tous les chemins
qu'il a traversés
il a croisé
toute la côte
d'Azote
jusqu'à Césarée
et la Bible
va nous raconter
qu'en Césarée
il va établir sa famille
il va porter un impact
cette ville
deviendra pour Paul
une ville très stratégique
pour ses voyages missionnaires
et dans sa maison
très pieuse
on voit la citation
qu'il avait
quatre filles
qui prophétisaient
ce qui montre
la piété
et l'efficacité
d'un autre moment
d'un autre aspect
dans la vie de Philippe
il y a le nuque
qui part avec joie
il y a Philippe
qui continue
d'évangéliser avec joie
les deux engagés
dans l'évangélisation
mais c'est intéressant
de remarquer
Philippe
qui avait consacré
les meilleures années
de sa vie
avec pleine force
dans sa jeunesse
possiblement
entre 25 et 30 ans
maintenant
il va s'établir
à Césarée
pour être
aussi efficace
de manière
plus stable
de longue durée
dans un même lieu
en formant une famille
pour porter un impact
dans cette société
et donc
qu'il n'importe
dans quel moment
de nos vies
et qu'il n'importe
où nous sommes
nous sommes toujours
en train de célébrer
l'évangile
et de faire promouvoir